[Music]
hey everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
back to Fandango indie movie Guide it's
just two weeks until the Oscars so I am
up to one of the biggest categories so
far my predictions Best Director and the
nominees are Christopher Nolan Jordan
Peele Greta Gerwig Paul Thomas Anderson
and Guillermo del Toro the interesting
thing here is all but one of these
directors have never been nominated for
a Best Director Academy Award before the
one exception being Paul Thomas Anderson
but starting with Christopher Nolan and
yes it's hard to believe that he's never
been nominated before for Best Director
but he has in the screenplay category
but Don Kirk was really a technological
masterpiece and a lot of it came down to
the brilliant direction Nolan had the
great idea of using almost a ticking
clock throughout the whole film which
made it feel really tense and it tells
three different layers of story about
the Battle of Dunkirk using three
different lengths of time a week at the
beach a day at the sea and an hour in
the air you're fighting beaches
for fight on the landing grounds
we'll never surrender Jordan Peele is
now the fifth african-american to be
nominated for Best Director for his
brilliant horror film get out and he
also wrote the screenplays so this film
is completely his vision one that he
wanted to make for a long time it takes
a lot of the horror tropes and subverts
them making a very smart movie about
this post racist world quote-unquote
Chris was just telling me how he's
gotten much more comfortable with my
being you and Greta Gerwig is only the
fifth woman to ever be nominated for
Best Director and it's such a charming
story a mother-daughter relationship
about a young girl who grew up in
Sacramento where Greta Gerwig is also
from but dreams of moving to New York
and living a life in the arts
Lady Bird is that your given name why is
it in quotes I gave it to myself it's
given to me by me Paul Thomas Anderson
aka PTA is no stranger to this category
and he's here for phantom thread he's
got one of the most brilliant
filmography surround tackling all
different genres and the surprising
thing about phantom threads for me was
how funny it is very dark - and quite
surprising Daniel day-lewis is wonderful
as is Vicki creeps and I love the
cinematography and the fabulous score by
Johnny green woods you can so almost
anything into the garments secrets
and the shape of water is gamma del
Toro's ticket into the oscars finally
after such a long career in movies
he is truly a master of the modern day
monster film with his magical realism /
fairytale / monster melodrama somehow
working together to be a wonderfully
romantic films during sally hawkins and
doug jones who often works with gal mo
del toro here playing the leading man
the leading fish man these people really
represent the best the brightest the
most established and most original
voices working in film today and I think
it'll go to Guillermo del Toro for shape
of water
he has been winning all the awards thus
far in this category he very much
deserves that for this movie and for his
career it is definitely a wonderful
achievement and just so beautiful to
watch we'll soon see if I am correct in
this category but let's go now to what
you can see in theaters and at home this
weekend in theaters is a really cute
little rom-com called - the boy
downstairs this is written and directed
by Sophie Brooks it stars Zosia Mamet as
a girl who moves back to New York from
London only to find that the apartment
she's leased is right above her ex
boyfriend awkward
[Music]
it's the ex-girlfriend thing to do tease
me I mean I didn't know that you've
lived there oh my god are you okay I'm
fine we're gonna get a new cat where'd
the Blood come from this movie is full
of charm the two leads have wonderful
chemistry and I love the way that it
goes back and forth in time so you
slowly piece together what happened in
this relationship I recommend checking
out the boy downstairs if you can find
it in theaters this weekend I thought
that if I ended it then it would be less
painful in Iran but it wasn't
I think about you all the time
and if you're staying home this weekend
check out novitiate on Fandango now
directed by Maggie Betts this centers on
a gal who feels a very strong calling to
become a nun right at the time when the
church was trying to banish some of the
more extreme forms of punishment for
these young nuns in training I would
like you to use the disciplines let's go
to stop I don't think you really
understand this difference this little
exquisite drama has beautiful
performances from a mainly female cast
it is emotional and it talks a lot about
growing up and becoming a woman you can
see novitiate on Fandango now right now
so my question is what is it that really
does still matter
so as always let me know in the comments
below who you think will get Best
Director I want to hear your predictions
you can also find me on Twitter at
Alicia Malone and I'll see you next week
for the big one Best Picture bye
[Music]